hey guys it is the 22nd of September my
name is just McDonald and you're
watching Gamespot news let's get on with
the good
stuff first up if you grab yourself a
copy of final fantasy type0 HD you'll
also be able to get your hands on a
pretty meaty demo of Final Fantasy 15
Square Enix reckon you'll be able to
squeeze 3 to 4 hours of play time out of
the demo which is set in the DUS Sky
Region and it might last a little longer
if you decide to go it on foot instead
of hopping in your sweet convertible the
demo consists of at least one dungeon
the aforementioned driving and a fair
bit of exploration although it does not
feature any boss fights Assassin's Creed
has gone full Inception today by putting
a whole new Assassin's Creed game inside
the DLC of another Assassin's Creed game
specifically you can find the new title
in the season pass for Assassin's Creed
Unity should you you choose to Shell out
30 bucks you'll get access to new Unity
missions weapons gear and skills as well
as a new AC game set in China the aptly
named game called Assassin's Creed
Chronicles China is set in the 16th
century and is a 2.5d sidescroller
featuring female assassin Shia Jun a
character you'd know about if you ever
watched the animated film Assassin's
Creed Embers Shia John was trained by
AC's ETO and is on a Revenge mission
against those who destroyed her
Brotherhood the game has an art style
inspired by brush paintings and features
new martial arts focused skills and gear
the unity DLC itself also includes the
dead King story campaign which you can
read more about on Gamespot finally if
it's more Destiny loots you want then
it's more Destiny loots you shall have
and we know how to find it the internet
has uncovered a cave in Destiny's old
Russia Hub which contains an easy place
for farming mad loot drops it's an
endless spawn point for low-level
enemies who are unfortunately for them
generally carrying around the kinds of
things you'd kill them to get your hands
on for strategy gaming has released a
video guide on how to get the most out
of your cave farming while Reddit has
published a good cave etiquette guide
for gamers suggesting they not run up
every time they see something shiny drop
players will need to Rally around the
cave in groups of two or more and stand
in a certain point for the Bad Dudes to
spawn where they'll proceed to drop
uncommon gear and blue and Gams over a
period of time as for your question of
the day let me know if there's enough
packed into the Assassin's Creed DLC for
you to drop money on it or not that is
it for me today if you're looking for
more sweet news stuff we've got all the
cool things that came out of TGs onsite
and I'll see you same time
[Music]
tomorrow